I'm delighted you could all join us
today uh it's heartening to see so many
familiar faces whilst welcoming many new
ones as well
you being here is a testament to how far
United for wildlife has grown
our natural world is one of our greatest
assets
it is a lesson I learned from a young
age from my father and my grandfather
both committed naturalists in their own
right
and also for my much missed grandmother
who cares so much for the natural world
in times of loss it is a comfort to
honor those who Miss through the work we
do
and I take great Comforts then from the
progress we're making to end the illegal
Wildlife trade
eight years ago we set out to develop a
solution to one of the largest yet often
overlooked International crimes
blighting our world
a crime that robs us all of our most
precious natural resources and funds
organized crime
the harms of which are often directly
felt by the most vulnerable communities
at a crime that this year felt
especially brutal
the devastating news about Ranger Anton
mizimba is shocking confirmation of how
vicious the illegal Wildlife trade is
Anton dedicated himself to the
protection of Wildlife
undertaking his role diligently and
professionally despite threats to his
life
he stood up to Violent criminals and
paid the ultimate price
it is only right that we pay tribute to
him and all the other selfless ranges
and Frontline conservationists here
today
and is also only right that we honor him
by continuing our work with renewed
focus and vigor
it is of course a difficult mission that
we commit ourselves to
the challenges often cited in fighting
Wildlife crime include the lack of a
coordinated International response
the lack of strong criminal justice
corruption and insufficient resources
but we set out to reverse that
we set out to ensure that those involved
in Wildlife crime face an international
response as powerful and coordinated as
any other serious and organized crime
to bring their Sinister operations out
to the Shadows
and to ensure that communities are
equipped empowered and supported
to protect themselves and their natural
world
and everyone here is playing a
significant role in helping us do that
in the six years since creating our
International transport and financial
task forces we have brought together
over 250 enforcement agencies
transport companies financial
institutions and other corporations in
the shared commitment to combat the
illegal Wildlife trade
we've contributed to over 450 Law
Enforcement cases over 250 arrests
almost 200 seizures of wildlife products
and we've helped to train over a hundred
thousand people
we only have to look back to August to
find examples of this work paying off
was sentenced to over five years in
prison for conspiring to traffic more
than seven million dollars worth of
rhino horn and elephant ivory
involving illegal poaching of around 135
animals
U.S authorities led the way in this case
but critical to its success was the
collaboration of a broad range of
organizations across multiple continents
United for wildlife members were among
them assisting with a landmark case that
sent a clear message to the criminal
gangs facilitating Wildlife trafficking
you will face serious consequences
our work is far from complete and
there's so much more still to be done
but there is cause for optimism
this year Colombia became the first
country to sign our Bucking Palace
declaration
reflecting the importance they place on
wildlife conservation and protection
I invite more to join them
the international Maritime organization
created its first ever guidelines on how
to combat the illegal Wildlife trade
following discussions with United for
wildlife and task force members
we recently launched our fifth Regional
chapter in Dubai following East Africa
southern Africa Hong Kong southeast Asia
and australasia
and we look forward to launching many
more in the months ahead
every week our members share information
develop new technologies and train more
people to strengthen our Collective
response
this is exemplified best by two public
private Partnerships in Southern and
East Africa facilitated by United for
wildlife
the South African anti-money laundering
integrated task force has developed an
expert group focused on Wildlife crime
putting it on a par with its other
expert groups addressing the financing
of terrorism and human trafficking
it is already having an impact assisting
in the seizure of 78 horns Ivory and
other wild eye products and a number of
arrests
looking ahead I'm pleased to announce
that the East and Southern Africa
anti-money laundering group comprising
19 countries will formally enter into an
agreement with United for wildlife
marking the first International public
private partnership for any Financial
crime
thanks to your collaboration and Forward
Thinking our activity is having a
demonstrable impact
and while we do not have the luxury of
time clearly we do have a proven roadmap
to success
and the motivation to put it into action
I hope you all leave here today
energized and motivated to intensify
this work
because there are still too many
criminals who believe they can act with
impunity
Too Many Lives being destroyed
and too many species on the brink of
Extinction due to this heinous crime
and so I call on all of you here today
and those involved in United for
wildlife further afield
keep breaking the mold
keep Building Bridges and making those
game-changing connections
keep believing that this is a crime that
can be ended once and for all
because I know with your commitment it
can
thank you
[Applause]